this is sort of interesting and also
funny and also sad we'll see where you
ultimately come down on it we used to
interview people from the Westboro
Baptist Church this is that infamous
Church located in Topeka Kansas known
for their God hates [ __ ] slogan they're
known for protesting soldiers funerals
and blaming anything bad that happens on
either homosexuality or bisexuality or
more recently transgenderism there was a
just insane viral incident that took
place on the show back in 2011 where
anonymous someone from the hacktivist
group Anonymous actually hacked the
Westboro Baptist Church web site during
a debate with Shirley phelps-roper that
clip has must be six or seven million
views on YouTube at this point and over
the years we've interviewed Shirley
phelps-roper and margie phelps and
Jonathan Phelps all children of the late
Fred Phelps the founder of the Westboro
Baptist Church we've also interviewed
Steve drain who sort of not married in
but kind of like joined the Westboro
Baptist Church from outside any family
of Fred Phelps and we haven't had them
on for years because they're just less
present recently I don't think they're
particularly relevant we got a call a
couple weeks ago from a viewer saying
hey David when do you decide how do you
decide when to no longer interview an
extremist and I talked about it being
kind of a balance between the notoriety
that they have and the relevance of
their ideas and that we make a
calculation about whether it's worth
refuting their terrible ideas or if it's
better to just kind of ignore them and
basically we've been ignoring the
Westboro Baptist Church for years at
this point until a producer Noah
Ferguson told me that the Westboro
Baptist Church was going to be near him
yesterday at Virginia Commonwealth
University his alma mater they
apparently the catalyst for being in
Virginia at all was that Danica Rome
became the first transgender person to
be elected to a u.s. state legislature
in Virginia so the Westboro Baptist
Church decided to start out with a big
protest at the Virginia State Capitol
where the protest group itself was
actually pretty small but a
counter-protest group was more prominent
also the lead singer
from Lamb of God was there leading a
drum circle very very close to the
protestors it was just a completely
wacky and raucous scene as is often the
case anywhere that the Westboro Baptist
Church appears and then the Westboro
Baptist Church went from the state
capitol over to Virginia Commonwealth
University to VCU so producer Noah
Ferguson went down there to try to talk
to them police were all over the
Westboro Baptist Church people trying to
make sure that nobody does anything to
them Shirley phelps-roper had this big
boom box playing music and all sorts of
media kept trying to talk to her and two
other Westboro members and police
wouldn't let them get close enough
Shirley kept the boom box really loud
and this is hilarious
Noah Ferguson was able to get close
enough to say to Shirley
he's from the David Pakman show and
Shirley immediately turns down the music
and actually starts talking to Noah
Ferguson and Noah explains to the police
officers that are nearby that we
actually know Shirley which is just
hilarious what I can't imagine what's
burning through the police officers mind
and she said during this impromptu
question-and-answer session with Noah
that she'd be willing to come on the
show weirdly at one point she seems to
sort of suggest that our entire audience
is transgender but maybe there's like a
grammatical ambiguity let's take a look
at the video you'll hear the music
blasting from the boombox at first
shirley eventually turns it down and
then actually talks to Noah Ferguson
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
we know each other it's cool yeah many
times
we haven't had you one in a while you
would you be wanting to come back on
what are you out of your protest that's
really that's really interesting do you
still think David Pakman is going to
hell is everyone at David Patty's RT
it's going to help taking the subgroup
of sodomites called transgenders and
elevated it again with lightning speed
to a position of respect in this country
what God has called an abomination and
he said you would be willing to come
back on our show what do you think you
guys would want to talk about if you
came back on
I actually think Pat that at the
beginning I say I think she thinks Noah
is David Pakman she almost it seems like
she kind of says oh we know each other
or I know him we've talked before and I
think later she realizes that it's not I
haven't flown down to Virginia to talk
to her at some random protest and then
she realized that she's talking to
someone who works for the David Pakman
show yeah there very well could be some
mental illness going on there especially
given that she implied that our audience
is made up entirely of transgender
individuals which I don't believe to be
the case no so I think I couldn't tell
whether she was saying our audience is
transgender individuals or our audience
has elevated transgender individuals in
some way that I guess she finds
deplorable or whatever but in any case
there's Shirley phelps-roper just as a
quick note I would never advocate for
violence to be allowed against anyone
when police are in a position to stop it
but when I think back to the
Charlottesville Virginia neo-nazi rally
one of the bigger problems there was
that police weren't able to sort of like
properly be set up to protect people and
from violence and someone ended up dying
there and tons of people ended up
severely beaten by right-wing protesters
here the police is very securely formed
a perimeter around Shirley phelps-roper
and the Westboro Baptist Church people
just just an observation and as far as
them being back on the show I think it's
basically over I don't think the
audience is interested in hearing from
the Westboro Baptist Church but if I'm
wrong and you are interested in hearing
from them by all means get in touch and
we can reach back out to Shirley and see
what it is she wants to talk about